我们做人不可以这么自私的，
就是我不喜欢他，
在亲密关系上我跟他不合适，
我不可以这么自私的，
因为这是一条明摆着，
这是一条对他不负责任的路，
对我自己也不负责任的路的。
我今年01年的，
现在在一家私企上班，
工资6000左右，
然后双休有一天一薪，
但是我本人身体不是很好，
就是有我太以前的乙肝体系啊什么的，
身体就是不是特别好，
我刚接触一段恋情，
我谈了一个211的研究生男朋友，
我不知道要怎么接受他，
你这个是乙肝，
是现在有传染性吗？
是有的，
那自己有去想办法去治疗一下吗？
有的就现在在吃药，
是现在吃药啊，
就是说现在有人追你，
你没跟人家说你有乙肝，
是这样吗？
不是，
分手之后他又找我复合了，
那你跟人家谈的时候，
你跟他说过你有乙肝有传染性吗？
他什么都知道，
我也跟他说过，
那他有去打预防针吗？
有的，
那现在又找你复合，
对，
但是我不是很喜欢他，
但是我家庭我妈因为乙肝到现在有肝癌，
我也觉得不应该耽误他是么？
因为我也怕我以后也会这样子，
不是的，
我感觉你们这些女孩。
孩子就是被那种韩剧的偶像剧给洗脑了，
韩剧的偶像剧老是这个桥段，
男主角生病了，
就决绝的跟女主角要分手，
要让女主角发现自己出了，
发现自己怎么怎么让女主角恨自己，
女主角就出国了，
然后自己了女主角又来哭，
或者说反过来说啊，
女主角自己得什么病了，
也是要一定要让男主角误会，
我跟别人好上了，
然后男主角特别痛苦，
特别恨我，
然后我默默的死掉，
然后男主角再来我坟上哭。
韩剧都这样，
但是我觉得我们做人不应该这样，
我们做人应该是什么？
第一我对我自己的身体健康负责任，
我知道我自己身体有什么问题的话，
我该治我就治，
对吧，
现在就是有传染性，
他可以控制成没有传染性，
这个是可以做到的，
对不对，
现在的医学是可以做到的，
那我就先把我自己的这个身体搞好了，
第二我不骗人，
我不欺骗，
我不隐瞒，
如果以后我搞对象的话，
我就明说我以前得过乙肝，
具有传染性，
但是经过我自己的调理，
我自己的治疗，
我现在已经不具备传染性了，
如果说你还是担心和害怕的话啊，
你可以去打一个疫苗，
就是乙肝的那个预防针，
可以去打一下，
这样你有乙肝抗体的话，
也就不影响了，
但是呢，
我要告诉你的是，
我的妈妈是得肝癌的，
那也就是说我可能存在这样的风险，
将来可能会发展成这样，
当然这个东西的话也未必，
那我自己的话，
我不喝酒，
我不。
抽烟，
我对自己的身体负责任，
我吃的清淡，
我对肝没有太多的这个负担的话，
我就，
呃，
隔个一年我就去体检啊，
我年年都去体检，
都去查肝，
是不是我对我自己负责任，
然后我把选择权交给对方，
如果你对我的爱确实是你觉得你愿意去承担这些的话，
那我尊重你，
而且我也不会说预设我跟你一定能过到老吗？
你对我的爱一定能够抵抗这些吗？
未必，
我享受当下的每时每刻，
我享受每一天，
其实人的一生就是若干个切片组成的，
我就享受当时当下的切片就完事了。
至于有一天他说他不想跟我好了，
那就算我身体很健全，
他也未必想跟我好，
就算有一天我生病了，
他不想跟我好了，
我尊重你，
我理解你，
我祝福你啊。
嗯，
不好意思，
我可能有点紧张，
我说话有点慢，
其实我想说的是，
因为我现在想早一点结婚，
然后生小孩，
我跟他在一起的时候，
他就知道我的身体都有情况，
然后后面我们分手了，
我又谈了一段新的恋情，
他也等了我一年多，
现在我分手，
他又过来找我复合，
我现在就在纠结，
因为我也没有同意要和他复，
但是我觉得他是一个非常有责任心，
以家庭为重，
然后上进心也特别强的一个男孩子。
你当初。
跟人家分手是你提的，
对不对？
对，
因为我你为什么跟人家提分手，
是因为你不喜欢他对不对，
不是不喜欢他，
是我要那方面不是很和谐，
不和谐就是不和谐，
他也不会，
因为说你谈了另外一个男朋友了，
现在就变和谐了呀，
那你就是说犹豫要不要，
因为说她有责任心，
收入也不错，
家庭也不错，
要不要妥协，
要不要跟她在一起，
是不是他家境也比较穷，
然后我家庭比他好，
我就是很纠结要不要和他在一起，
因为我想早一点生下，
好，
我想早一点结婚啊，
不行的姑娘，
我们做人不可以这么自私的，
就是我不喜欢他，
在亲密关系上我跟他不合适，
我不可以这么自私的，
因为这是一条明摆着，
这是一条对他不负责任的路，
对我自己也不负责任的路的，
我没有不真诚，
我就是很什么都跟他，
我只是比较紧张，
我比较紧，
因为这是我自己，
自己啊，
没事儿啊，
姑娘啊，
而且从另一个角度来说的话，
像你们这种情况，
就是你先提分手，
你跟他就已经分手了，
然后你再跟别人谈一年，
完了之后他再回来找你，
像这种搭配的话，
也很难把日子过好，
很难的，
某种程度上，
人他都会有那种被伤害了之后，
都会有一些报心的，
就是你被抛弃了，
你心里会不会或多或少在你未曾意识到的阴暗的角落里面会有一点点报复心，
有没有，
如果是我的话，
我会有。
当初你甩我是吧？
就算我再爱你的话，
在我那个阴暗的角落里面，
我一定有一种报复心在，
可能我自己都无法控制或者无法意识得到这个报复心存在，
但他会在以后的生活矛盾当中会凸显出来，
因为人不是圣人，
很难有那种说修炼到爱一个人胜过或者说能够完全压抑我的本能，
完全能够覆盖我的这种报心。
我感觉这个世界上除了我的孩子之外，
没有人可以做到说让我压抑我自己的报复心，
你理解了吧？
就这个男的，
他心里，
就算他是一个善良的人，
在他心里某个阴暗的角落，
也有一种报复的性格存在，
报复你的那个欲望存在。
所以你要是跟他回头过的话，
想要过好挺难的，
这话真是对你负责任。
姑娘啊，
就这件事情，
你既要考虑到人性的阴暗面，
也要考虑到就是我自己的这份善良，
我自己的这份善良就是我要对我负责任，
同时我也要对别人负责任，
我不可以自私到因为我想生孩子，
因为我想怎么怎么样，
我就凑合让你来充当这样一个工具人不可以的。
我知道你比较纠结这个问题，
就是合适和喜欢吗还要选，
所以我就来问一下你这个问题，
好，
这是我给你的答案啊，
就是这条路太难走了，
复合这条路太难走了，
嗯，
好好嗯，
好，
拜拜，
我突然想到一个故事，
这个故事是什么呢？
是那个小贝，
以前大家都看过蜗居这个电视剧啊，
蜗居这个电剧当。
是好火的，
基本上就是好多人，
我们年轻这一代都看过蜗居这个电视剧，
他里面就有一个角色叫小贝，
但是他这个情况跟刚刚姑娘这个情况是不一样的啊，
但是小贝那个情况就是他发现他的女朋友跟别人就是把他给绿了嘛，
跟宋思明把他给绿了，
他心里也很想原谅他，
也很想跟海藻，
就是这件事情往前过啊，
这件事情我就翻篇儿了，
但是他做不到，
在他心里的那个被压抑的那个阴暗的角落里面就是有报复心的，
所以那会儿我看这个故事的时候，
我就明白了这个道理，
就这种情况下的话，
还是往前看，
就别回头了啊，
虽然说跟刚才连麦那个姐妹情况不太一样，
但是她逻辑是大差不差的，
当初你把他甩了，
你说不合适，
你要跟人家分手，
她一定是痛苦的，
一定是难过的，
一定是被抛弃的那种感觉，
她是植跟在一个人的基因里的，
她会受伤的，
受伤了就会产生一种报复心理啊，
可能他这种报复心理未必是说他打你，
他骂你，
但是他在内心的话，
他你没有看过那种，
就是当天领了结婚证，
当天那个语气都不一样了是吧？
当天领了结婚证，
当天就拿着那个结婚证就扇那个女孩的脸，
轻轻的扇啊，
开玩笑，
那个扇啊，
不是傲娇吗？
不是那个什么吗？
还不是被我搞到手了，
有没有看到我啊，
你不是校花，
你不是很牛吗？
还不是被我搞到手了，
对吧？
啊，
就这意思啊，
他可能玩笑里面带着他的一点点阴暗的那个面啊，
记得点赞关注哦。